[Applause]
and the Oscar goes
to Diablo
Cody
[Music]
Juna this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Diablo
[Music]
Cody
what is
happening um this is for the writers and
uh I I I want to thank all the writers I
especially want to thank the my my
fellow nominees because I I I worship
you guys and I'm I'm I'm learning from
you every day so thank you very much um
I want to thank the academy uh I want to
thank Fox Searchlight Mr mud mandate
Dand de Becky uh I want to thank our
incredible cast including the Superhuman
Ellen pagee
um uh I want to thank Jason rman who I
consider a member of my family and I I'm
in awe of his talent as a
filmmaker
um I want to thank Sarah s uh I want to
thank Mason novic who knew I could do
this before I did and most of all I want
to thank my family for loving me exactly
the way I am so
cute